(piano)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts from
diverse disciplines to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(techno music)
- Thanks very much for the opportunity
to come and talk with you today.
I'm going to speak about
our work on how crows
and other birds recognize
and respond to their dead.
The message is fairly
simple from what we know
at this point, I think that it mainly is
an opportunity for them to learn about
sources of death and
places to avoid and perhaps
other objects in the environment to avoid.
So I see it as a real arena for learning.
Before I get into the crows, I wanted to
step back to the mammals for just a second
and relate quite an
interesting observation
I had in Yellowstone National Park,
about four years ago to this day.
And at this point we were
with a group of students
looking at a wolf kill,
trying to assess the landscape
that might have contributed to this death.
And it was an old female that had died,
she'd been killed about two weeks earlier.
And the death scene was one
of a large cleft boulder,
the female had backed
into that, it was a bison
that had been killed by a pack of wolves.
And we were measuring the
aspects of the terrain
and the situation,
there was a lot of still
blood stained on the rock and the bones
of the dead female bison on the ground.
And as we were busying ourselves,
we heard a roar of hooves
come over the ridge,
and a whole herd of
about three dozen bison
displaced us from that scene.
And we felt pretty bad
for having been there
and interrupted this situation.
But the thing that was impressive was that
these bison, after they pushed us away,
they all smelled the
bones, much as we heard
with other mammals, and
then each one individually
walked through this cleft in the rock
right where the female had been killed
and passed through and
then went on their way.
They were there for
about an hour in total.
And that's very different than we see with
the response to when a
crow finds a dead animal.
So what you see in this
video are the responses
of crows to finding a
dead bird that we placed
on the ground right below
that telephone pole.
They come in, they're
very noisy, they gather
and they might last for 15 or 20 minutes
before they move on out of the area.
And this is a widespread
response that's been seen
in other members of this
family, the Corvidae,
that includes things like magpies,
which have been seen to
even bring tufts of grass
in to a dead magpie, or scrub jays,
there's been a lot of work on
scrub jays just north of us here,
and also ravens gathering around the dead.
So let me introduce you to
this family of birds briefly,
they're birds that are
familiar to most of us,
they live close by with us, they include
the ravens and crows,
magpies, jays, nutcrackers.
And they live around the world
in all the continents except Antarctica.
And almost all of these species have had
some sort of interaction, as I described
with the crows, to finding the dead.
So, some aspects of this group,
they're long lived,
they're typically social,
they have long lasting
partnerships with their mates
and sometimes extended family groups.
They have rather large
brains for their body size.
On this graph, these show
the average relationships
between body size on the X axis
and brain size on the Y axis
for things like fish and
here's the average bird line.
And then you'll see that the dots for the
various Corvids are well above
the bird line, more on the mammal line
and even some, like the American crow
that I study, right on the primate line.
So these are really more like small
flying monkeys than they are birds.
Their brains are quite complex.
We know now, in the last several decades,
that they include places in the brain
that are analogous and
also homologous to ours.
For example, the hippocampus
is a homologous structure.
And the amygdala is at least
an analogous structure.
They have a large forebrain,
all this area here,
there's a striatum, but a large forebrain
where more complex sorts
of sensory information
might be combined and considered.
And they have important
connections between
the forebrain and the thalamus
back up to the forebrain
that allows these animals
to reconsider actions
and shape them before they
act upon that information.
So the typical response is
to get some information in,
maybe from the eye,
process it in the forebrain
and send a response down the spinal cord
to the muscles to do something.
But they don't have to always do that
because of the connection here that allows
that information to go back to
the forebrain and be adjusted.
That's how they, for example,
learn different vocalizations.
So, with an animal like
that, long lived, social,
and quite cognitively nimble,
there are many reasons
why they might attend
their dead, as we discussed
just with Dora's presentation.
So they may be looking
at a social opportunity,
a vacant territory, a
potential mate for example.
They may looking to learn about danger.
They may be looking at
other aspects of that scene
to learn what caused the death,
what sort of expectation in the future
that area may hold for
danger and things like that.
They may also be grieving and mourning
a lost member of their
family, or, as I said,
since these animals mate for
life, they might have been
with this same individual that's dead now
for 20 or 30 years and might
have a profound relationship
and interaction with that
animal after it's lost.
So we have tried to investigate
this response by doing experiments.
And what we do is we basically prepare
taxidermy mounts of individual crows
and have them in kind of a dead status,
and then we place those out and see
the response of wild
birds to those mounts.
And this is a general description
basically of what we do.
There's some sort of a conditioning phase,
where we get animals used
to coming to an area.
Then we present them with some stimulus,
that could be a dead crow, or a hawk
for example, just to see the response.
And then we measure their response
after they've encountered that.
And during this time
we've been feeding them
at a spot, so we know
they reliably come in,
they're using that spot to gain food,
and we can look for a
change in their behavior,
maybe how long it takes
for them to approach
that food after they've
seen a dead bird there.
So what we've found and
this is work I should say
that my PhD student Kaylee Swift
and I have been engaged in,
and Kaylee's continuing
this work now, but these are
some of the early findings
that she discovered.
First off, in terms of
how many gatherings occur
around these dead crows, about 60 percent
of all the crows we put out had
a large mob form around them.
And that's similar to what you would see
if a hawk was present,
which is a known danger,
and it's not as often as you would see
if a hawk had a dead crow
in its grip for example,
that almost always elicits
this sort of response.
So from this, comparing to
more controlled situations
where just a person is there feeding,
or just food is provided,
suggests that this
is some sort of response
to danger for sure.
And we know that the
individuals are learning
something about being
in this dangerous place,
because their approach to
the food is quite different
after a danger has been
seen, versus not been seen.
So here you just see the amount of time
pre and post exposure to a stimulus.
In this case the stimulus is just food,
or a person, nothing
dangerous, no difference,
and if the stimulus is
a hawk or a dead crow,
much longer time to approach
that food after seeing that.
And this kind of narrows that response,
because actually in some cases the birds
refuse to come down to food
at a place they had seen
a dead crow for up to six to eight weeks.
And this is different also depending upon
whether it's a crow or
a pigeon that they see.
So they're very sensitive
to the type of stimulus.
They avoid places after
seeing a dead crow,
even though they had been
feeding there before,
but if a dead pigeon is placed there
there's no real response, no difference.
And also crows do this
and not all birds do this.
So we just controlled this by looking at
the response of pigeons, as well as crows,
to this sort of presentation.
And when pigeons see a
place they've been fed at
that now has a dead pigeon
at it, they continue to
feed there afterwards,
like nothing had happened.
I suspect turkeys, we've been
seeing some turkey videos
of turkeys walking
around a dead cat today,
and I suspect they act like
pigeons in this respect.
But crows clearly increase their hesitancy
to approach a spot after they've
seen a dead animal there.
And this is a pretty
nuanced response as well.
So what we see in this
graph is that the response
to an adult crow that's dead versus
a juvenile crow that's dead
over here, is different.
And that's especially different
during the breeding season.
So when you find a dead
juvenile crow in the
breeding season, which is
a fairly common response,
a lot of young birds die,
birds, the adult crows,
and other crows in the area
don't pay much attention
to that, they only scold
and form a mob about a third of the time.
Likewise during the breeding season
if an adult is found,
scolding and mobbing is
not as common as it is during
the non-breeding season.
So this sort of nuanced
response to me suggests
that this sort of
behavior is triggered more
by an ecological, or more
of a social or ecological
factor than it is perhaps
something like grieving
or mourning the loss of this individual.
In fact, I would expect the exact opposite
if they were really
considering, for example,
a lost young bird of
their own, their sibling
or their offspring, or their mate,
you would expect those responses to be
especially strong during
the breeding season,
for example, and especially
strong among adult birds.
So we have tried to
understand where in the brain
the crow is processing this information,
and using that to help
explain a little bit more
about why they're doing
this sort of thing.
And let me explain our procedure to you
a little bit here, in this slide.
We're doing PET imaging of live crows
as they view various sorts
of dangerous stimuli,
a hawk, a person that
had just captured them,
or a person holding a
dead crow for example.
And what we do, shown up here at the top,
is we capture our birds in the wild.
We wear a mask when we capture them,
so that they learn a
particular face associated with
that dangerous experience,
being captured in the wild.
We capture them with a
net gun that goes off
with a blast and pins them to the ground,
it's a pretty scary thing for a bird.
And we don't want them to
associate that with us,
when we see them later,
and we want to be able
to have anybody take on the role of that
dangerous person by putting on this mask.
So, we wear a mask when we catch them.
We then bring the birds into captivity
and care for them
wearing a different mask.
So we have one person that's good here,
caring for the birds, and
one person that's bad,
that has captured the bird.
And we keep the birds for about a month.
And during this time we bring
them in to a smaller cage,
shown in the middle diagram here,
where they are acclimated
overnight and then
the next morning we perform
a procedure upon them.
And that procedure is
simply to catch the bird
out of the cage, inject
it with a glucose mimic
that we use as a tracer to indicate
where synaptic activity, where nerve cells
are actively communicating
with one another.
And we then put them back in that cage,
after they've been given the
shot of glucose in their belly,
and then we show them something.
We let them, while they're awake, look out
and observe perhaps just
a person in the room
that they've never
seen, they could observe
the person that caught them, or the person
that cared for them, or a
person holding a dead crow,
or a hawk, or nothing at all.
And then, during that 20 minutes or so,
we continue to let them
see that person on and off.
And we then anesthetize
them, and this tracer
with the PET imaging
allows us to basically
step back in time, while
they're anesthetized,
and see where in the brain
that tracer has accumulated
during the time when they were actually
looking at that stimulus we gave them.
So this way we can keep
them still, get a nice image
and see what's going on in their brain,
then wake them up, let
them rest for a day,
let the tracer, the
radioactive tracer clear
and they can be released back to the wild.
So, for example, here's
what a crow would see
if it was sitting in our cage metabolizing
that glucose we gave it
and looking out and seeing
a person it had never seen
before holding a dead crow.
The images we get of
their brain are striking,
they show relative activity by how bright
the areas are here, this
is the glucose fluorescing
basically in the tomography,
and what you see here
are bright spots on either
hemisphere of the brain
which are the entopallium of the bird,
that's the visual processing
center of a bird's brain
assessing information coming
from the two eyes here.
I'm going to show you a set of graphs
that look somewhat like
this, figures that basically
show MRIs in gray, to show you the
structure of the bird's brain,
and then the red areas indicate what parts
of the brain were most
activated in a given set
of birds that saw one
thing, versus a set of birds
that saw something quite different.
And in this case, this
shows the part of the brain
and this is the front
part of the bird's brain,
that's activated when they
saw a person in the room,
versus nobody else in the room,
so any kind of person in this case.
There's a lot of higher order processing
occurring in the forebrain of these birds
as they consider that person,
and also in the striatum
as they possibly are making
connections between that person
and something that it had previously done.
Now if we look at them
in response to basically
how they see particular
people, what we have
on the top panel here
is the response of birds
when they looked out
and they saw the person
that had previously captured
them, so a dangerous person.
And they're recalling, at this point,
something about that person.
They already know that he was dangerous,
and now what we see
activated most clearly,
in addition to that frontal area
that I showed previously,
is their amygdala.
So they're basically responding like
other vertebrates do
with a strong response
in the right hemisphere of their brain,
in the amygdala region, that indicates
they're responding to a known danger,
a learned danger I should say.
In contrast, when they see a person
that they've never seen before
and they're learning about
that person's behavior,
because it's holding a dead crow,
what is activated most strongly
is the hippocampus in the bird.
So what we interpret is going on here
is that these birds are
acquiring information,
they're learning about
this dangerous person,
by its association with a
dead crow, and in this case
they're recalling
something already learned.
We know something about the
way information proceeds
from the eyes up to the bird's brain.
And I just show you this diagram
to point out the complexity with which
this information travels from the retina
up through the basal ganglia
and into the forebrain.
And it's a rather simple picture actually
when they're looking at a person
that they've learned to be threatening,
as compared to the situation when they're
first assessing somebody
that's potentially
dangerous by in fact
holding this dead crow.
So here the hippocampus
is involved as well
as the forebrain and the
visual processing centers,
and in this case it's mainly the forebrain
and the visual processing
centers interacting.
So all of these field experiments
and laboratory experiments
basically point me
to one conclusion, when
we show a crow a dead crow
that's not a familiar individual,
that they're responding
and learning about that situation,
perhaps the person associated with it,
or the place associated with that death,
quite clear I think in this respect to me.
But what else could we be missing?
And to me this is the more interesting
part of the work that we basically,
I can only tell you I don't know,
but I hope to find out at some point.
But this is a pair of ravens
interacting with one another.
They form very close relationships,
and surely, I would guess,
we would see differences
in the brain activity of a bird after it
had lost its mate, than
if it just encounters
a dead bird that it
doesn't know personally.
But we haven't done that experiment,
it's something that could be done,
but ethically is difficult to do.
There are other things
that suggest there may be
a lot more going on than
just learning about a site.
And these are more anecdotal observations.
I mentioned earlier that
when magpies come in
to their dead, they've been
observed to carry grass.
And maybe that's just the nesting material
that they were carrying
when they encountered that,
or maybe it was something more purposeful.
So, for example, in
crows this picture shows
one that was found that was
surrounded by these sticks.
There were no trees
around, there was nothing
where these sticks could have just
been there incidentally,
maybe a human put them there,
or perhaps the crow had come in and
put those sticks around this dead crow.
We don't know, but I have several
observations like this from people.
And then finally, just a
week ago, a woman sent me
this image which she took on the
Michigan State University campus.
And what you see here is a crow
that is looking at a dead crow,
the dead crow has only recently died.
The woman suggested it
might have hit a window
or something by the looks of it,
and this bird flew in, totally silent,
brought this piece of tinfoil in its bill
and set it down in front of the dead crow.
And it stood there for 20
minutes, watching this.
I have no idea if these are a mated pair,
or if, again, this was
anything other than incidental,
but it's curious to me
that they didn't scold,
this bird didn't scold and didn't
attract a crowd in, like we regularly see.
So I think there's much more going on here
than we know, and it will take much more
sophisticated experiments to get at them,
which hopefully we'll do in the future.
And with that I would thank you
very much for your attention.
(applause)
(techno music)